personally appreciate that
at the end of the day the number of
doses available to us to allocate
ended up being lower and so as we gave
forecasts to the jurisdictions
and governors and states work their
priorities against those forecasts
when we had to decide what was going to
eventually be shipped out
i had to lower the allocations to meet
the releasable doses
that were presented to me we look at
this
every day and every week
all right and only when i am confident
that the vaccine is releasable and that
i have first and second doses can
i move it forward so to the governors
to the governor's staffs please accept
my personal apology
uh if this was disruptive in your
decision-making
and in your conversations with the
people of your great state
i will work hard to correct this of
every vaccine that is distributed i
personally updated secretary azar on
where we think we are with numbers
we remain on track to allocate 20 around
20 million doses of vaccine
to the all jurisdictions by the end of
december
with distribution of those doses pushing
into the first week
of january i ask us all to stay focused